hello into welcomed video playing I am
super Mouse said Vietnam yep with known
okay um g3 okay maybe b6 try to set up
like that we only double fine kettle
adds an interesting interesting setup I
wonder have a clean plate the best move
water I doubt it after kobe 7 okay yeah
i don't like to play six but probably
probably have to oh just goes back okay
yeah we have the Hedgehog now try to the
techie forum see how he reacts to that
maybe even create as possible oh wow
that's very sophisticated okay f3 is not
something that looks very scary some of
each for possible here now you will
probably go G for tech age 5 is still a
generally quite useful move and
interesting idea could be a 5 92 nite
moves and b5 I'm not sure that this
actually does work
yeah h4 looks wrong it's not so easy a
job to improve and probably the long
diagonal is not nothing it's nothing
left to do them this is potentially
preparing be 5 e 59 rules b5 this kind
of thing I really tough to judge right
to deserve you this before
maybe we groove to enter to dnc file
that's not an easy job for YTM my this
Bishop a eight and then e 59 moves be
five
hmm
yeah hon it all easy rookie g2 looks
normal but it somehow seems reluctant to
play that this one okay so II 592 b5 he
might take and play night before
ok I can also bring in 9 35 it's also
interesting I really undecided here what
to do many interesting options
so he goes back to see two ideas now to
play h4 maybe maybe he can just take
that pawn that this may be possible
anyway this will explode in some kind of
time scrabble anyway have to make sure
not to get into too huge time pressure
here you would probably take it but
ripped it to Issus inviting Bishop age 6
stuff I'm threatening age 3 now so I
think he has to react in some way okay
night age 5 or take first so night h5 is
not working King age 7 may be a setup I
said move not sure f-4s a force tough
the tough move okay f no time so you can
easily spend a long time in this
position maybe it just takes be six here
it's possible
I'll go d5 and then everything will
explode not so that [ __ ] i'm not sure
that Bishop h6 is even an idea here ya
know it it will be ultra messy now note
that my queen is looking at the g3 porn
okay so Bishop takes I don't want to
create Queen so take with this and now
see there are a couple of things
possible the night night moving
somewhere interesting looking at g3
night d 3 is a move should be seven
though okay time Barney bishop age six
is also move but doesn't look too
convincing 97 and 97 actually that's
very simple just attack the night and
the bishop at to that took ages for that
simple move but I didn't see that the
bishop is unprotected I was always just
thinking about the g3 porn not not about
this unprotected bishop situation so I
grabbed this
and so as I expected everything really
exploded okay I'm Knight f6 I guess
ready for Luke h8 check k Knight to f5
no I didn't want to do that of course
him check check check me okay that was
close he got really fast at the end
Gavin I don't know typical Hedgehog
trench warfare you have no idea what's
going on really yeah I don't know I
really have I have no idea about those
positions even though i have played them
a lot with with both sides more against
it more against the head shock that
actually with it but
I always have a hard time to figure out
what's going on yeah here probably d5
wasn't move just to just open it up with
rook and queen opposing and this looks
fatty fatty good okay but this is just
keeping the tension and I don't really
think it's bad it just feels like
relatively know a kind of Hedgehog yeah
I was thinking about various ways to
open up the position that the comp gives
this which is interesting yeah that was
kind of ideas what oh sorry this of
course he adds an interesting triad this
b5 I was never really sure about it
because why it also has this kind of
idea and often it's it's kind of its
leading nowhere quite often not sure
here though it's it's it's really
interesting ok I have decided to get the
night over to e5 because I wanted to
look at those pawns more each form and
this tape sticks oh well that's a very
very nice engine move this is a nice
mole wow that's really cool I mean this
is just an awful yeah with black getting
two points for the exchange and
fantastic play on the dark squares so um
blackwell what would you do here i will
take this and then we continued this is
the engine suggestion if white now takes
him like gets enough play with this
which is very difficult
of course in a blitz Kim you know if I
forgot I've got this at the end
potential discoveries ok King age seven
Queen B 6 and now a five yeah now it's
it gets gets totally chaotic and he
rather quickly blundered something even
though it took me of how to see it I was
just I was completely focused on doing
something here right with the Queen and
I never saw only later saw that this is
an unprotected piece I had ideas like
that but this is just not working yet
after this I'm winning pretty pretty
easily yeah yeah even though he got very
very fast now from this position and I
shouldn't have given the exchange that
was a mistake I tend to do that yet try
to give material back to make it simpler
maybe with the time this time scramble
but sometimes I make life and actually
more difficult I mean here it was always
winning but I had some problems now
because he was just appreciating like
crazy and I was happy that that I could
have checkmated him already then then I
then I got him into a mating net that
made the wind a lot lot quicker okay
thanks for watching